new tonight newly elected Trustees for  Clark County School Board sworn in  Brenda Zamora and Irene Bustamante are  first-time board members while Linda  Cavazos was elected to a third term now  there have been multiple reports of  infighting between board members lately  so the new board members are certainly  aware of it and they hope to bring  change  they're watching the parents are  watching teachers the whole community  and they need to restore their trust and  our leadership one of my priorities is  the public comment because I know I'm a  working mom as well you know and they  were very helpful to me to stay  connected  now overall the trustees say it was a  heartwarming night and they're looking  forward to making an impact in our  school district